tengo este objeto con cuentas y se me
ocurre que puedo utilizarlo para hacer
sumas tal vez sea de utilidad la verdad
es que nunca lo he hecho pero me gusta
experimentar y voy a empezar por una
suma simple utilizando números de un
solo dígito voy a sumar 7 + 5
entonces empezamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 muy
bien ahora voy a sumar el 5 entonces
tengo 1 2 3
alto tenemos que hacer algo porque en
esta posición sólo hay 10 cuentas y
entonces lo que voy a hacer es utilizar
una de la siguiente posición que tenga
el valor de 10 de la posición anterior
por lo que puedo reemplazar una de estas
que vale ahora 10 de la posición
anterior muy bien entonces 73 vale 10
pero tengo que completar el 5 así que 4
y 5 estaba yo sumando 75 sume 75 y
resulta 12 75 es igual a 12 10 más 2 muy
bien
pero me doy cuenta que lo que estoy
haciendo implica un acarreo y también
quiero pensar en cómo contamos
a ver vamos a ver normalmente cuando
contamos en una posición llegamos hasta
el 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y no
representamos el número 10 en una sola
posición para hacer 10
lo que hacemos es utilizar la siguiente
posición
muy bien así es como contamos y se
aplica para todas las posiciones bueno
yo creo que es el momento de hacer una
suma más complicada
qué les parece si sumamos 23 77 bien
primero voy a empezar por el 23 entonces
aquí ya tengo 10 y si pongo otra cuenta
de las que tienen valor 10 10 y 10 son
20 y si tomo 3 de las que tienen un
valor de 11 2 y 3 ya tengo 23 20 3 23
muy bien ahora voy a sumar el 77 voy a
empezar por el 7 entonces uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete y observo que ya
tengo diez en esta posición por lo que
puedo reemplazar todas estas por una de
la siguiente posición ahora vamos a
sumar el 70 10 20 30 40 50 60 70
y otra vez puedo reemplazar por una de
la siguiente posición las 10 que tengo
en esta posición muy bien y entonces
ahora tengo una que vale 100 2377 es
igual a 100
tengo una cuenta en la posición de las
que valen 100 0 cuentas en la posición
de las que valen 10 y 0 cuentas en la
posición de las que valen 1 muy bien 23
más 77 es igual a 100